[Music]
logan paul gives his first TV interview
since receiving backlash over that
controversial video i am a good guy who
made a bad decision i will think twice
in the future about what I post probably
three times the 22 year old YouTube star
spoke with Good Morning America as
Michael Strahan on Thursday here's how
he explained his decision to post the
controversial video which showed a man
who had apparently taken his own life in
Japan so-called suicide forest the idea
was to shock and show the harsh
realities of suicide and get people
talking about something that I don't
think people are talking about much he's
now calling the decision a horrible
lapse in judgment it's been tough
because ironically I'm being told to
commit suicide myself as for his
takeaway I believe it happened for a
reason and I think that reason is so I
could take this experience learn from it
spread the message the right way about
suicide prevention Paul also released a
suicide prevention video to YouTube last
week meanwhile ET exclusively sat down
with dr. Phil who thinks Paul can make a
comeback what went up on the video and
what was shown was tasteless it was
atrocious but let's call timeout here
this is a 22 year old young man and this
is one thing one time one bad decision
let's not judge this young man's whole
life his whole body of work everything
that he's done over one bad decision
[Music]